FEMALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
It's my pleasure to welcome
Magnus Nilsson to Google.
MAGNUS NILSSON:
I'm going to talk
a little bit about Nordic
food culture, in general.
And then I'm going to talk
a little bit about the book
that I've written about
it, "Nordic Cook Book."
Nordic food culture is
kind of interesting,
because it doesn't
really mean anything.
Because the Nordic Region, it's
simply a geographical area.
It's not a homogeneous cultural
region or anything like that.
So there's a lot of diversity
and a lot of variation
within the region itself.
And it's quite
difficult to define.
And it's actually,
like, on these events,
I try to do like a little
raise of hands, which
is quite fascinating to
see, how people's knowledge
about the region itself is.
So how many in here
can say with certainty
what the difference is
between the Nordic Region
and Scandinavia?
[LAUGHTER]
So that was an unusually
poor result, zero.
It's usually about 10%,
I find, that at least
think that they can do that.
So Scandinavia, which is
a cultural region as well
as a geographical region, it's
Sweden, Denmark, and Norway,
and nothing else.
And the Nordic Region, it's
Scandinavia plus Finland,
in the east, and then Aland,
in between Finland and Sweden
in the Baltic Sea,
the Faroe Islands,
between Iceland and
Scotland, and Iceland itself,
and Greenland.
So it's a much,
much bigger area.
And as you can imagine,
there's also, like,
a lot of diversity
within such a vast area.
So the natural circumstances
in the southeast of Finland
are quite different from what
you'll find west of Greenland.
And here you have
the whole region.
And as I said before, one of
the things that really define it
is the geographical vastness.
And one thing that is
another defining factor--
because I often get a question
about, like, pan-Nordic dishes.
And there are no such things
as a pan-Nordic dish, something
that exists everywhere.
But one thing that ties all
of these different countries
and regions together,
though, is the climate.
Because regardless where
you are in the region,
you're going to have four
distinctive seasons, of which
at least one of them is going
to be one where you can't really
harvest anything, in
terms of plant foods.
You know, there's going to be a
real winter-- except for maybe,
like, a little piece of
the very south of Denmark.
And this thing is something that
really ties the whole region
together-- the need to
produce an excess in summer,
and store it for winter,
and then consume it
during the dark months.
And like, one really
good example of a dish
that's-- it's not
pan-Nordic, and I said--
but it's kind of as close
as you can get to that.
And that's really,
really defined
by this thing with, you
know, having a proper winter,
is the open sandwich.
Basically a slice of
bread with a topping
and not putting that unnecessary
other slice of bread on top,
like you guys do.
And why is it so important?
And why is it found in
the whole region then?
And simply, because
grains, cereals,
they're one of the best ways
of collecting solar energy
in the summer and
then storing it
through winter to
be consumed when you
don't have much solar energy.
And the thing is that, if
you look at a sandwich,
it says so much about where it's
being prepared and consumed,
regardless of where you do
it in the world, you know.
And this obviously also
applies for the Nordic region.
And if we start at looking
at the bread-- obviously,
these days, you'll find,
like, crisp crusted baguettes
and stuff like that all
over the Nordic Region,
as much as you'll find
them anywhere else.
But if you look at the
more traditional breads
and why they make sense
where they are produced,
it is quite interesting.
And if we start with the loaf,
the loaf is a form of bread
that you kind of have to
eat relatively fresh, right?
It's best to eat in the same
day it's produced, or perhaps
within a couple of days
of the production date.
It means that you have
to bake loaves of bread
on a very regular basis for them
to have any chance in becoming
an everyday staple.
This in its turn, it
means that loaves of bread
as an everyday staple,
it can pretty much only
exist where you have bakeries.
Because no one is going
to bake their own bread
on an everyday basis.
And bakeries, they need
customers to sustain them.
So if you look at
the Nordic Region,
you have basically an area
from Stockholm and then south
over Denmark, which is
densely populated enough
in a sort of longer
perspective historically
so that you can
actually have bakeries.
And the loaf of bread-- at least
if it's baked outside of tin,
if it's baked like
in a free-form way
in a traditional
oven-- it's also
something that needs
wheat to really function.
Because you need a lot of gluten
to shape the loaf and to make
it rise.
And wheat, it doesn't
really grow further north
than Stockholm either.
So these defining
factors means that slices
from a loaf of
bread is really kind
of a city occurrence, in
historical perspective,
and something you will
find in the southern parts
of the central parts
of the Nordics.
And then, if you go on
and look, for example,
in the north of Sweden
where I come from,
very little wheat grows there.
And it's also
scarcely populated.
Yentlin, which is my region,
it's the size of Denmark.
It's a sixth of the
surface of Sweden,
and it has about, today,
about one inhabitant
per square kilometer.
So not many people.
And no real cities up
until, like, 100 years ago.
And here, obviously,
there were no bakeries.
And to use the grains that
stored the solar energy
in summer, people had to kind
of prepare them in some way.
And because they couldn't
buy a loaf from a baker,
they bake bread themselves.
And because it's so
labor-intensive and so
expensive to heat your
ordinary wood-fired oven,
people couldn't do
that very often.
It was more like
perhaps an annual thing.
You did it once a year.
And each farm would have
their own big baking oven.
And perhaps late November, early
December, something like that,
for Christmas, when all
of the barley-- that's
the most common grain up there--
was harvested, and dried,
and prepared, you started
firing up the wood-fired oven.
It takes, like, a good
24 hours to get it up
to about 800 degrees
of temperature.
And the first thing you
did-- because the key
there is to make as much as
possible of that, you know,
the big effort of heating
the ovens-- the first thing
that people did was to
make very, very thin
and large flatbreads.
Like, we're talking about barley
dough rolled out to maybe two
millimeters of thickness.
Cooks really quickly, and
then when you take it out
of the oven, it also
dries really quickly.
And you can easily stack
them and store them
for a really long time.
And the way people would
eat them was basically
to simply break off a piece,
maybe put some butter on it
and bread, and just
eat it like that--
or, even, like, crumble
it up and soak it
in broths, or with some
culture milk, or, you know,
different preparations.
When those first very thin flat
cakes, destined to be dried,
were done cooking, the oven
had cooled down a little bit.
And we proceed by doing
soft flatbreads, which is
more of an annual luxury item.
A bit thicker, it's
basically the same dough,
maybe a little bit
of sugar in it,
a little bit thicker so that
you can fold them and eat
them fresh for a couple
days just after having
baked the yearly bread.
The third bread to be
baked was another thing
that people used
to make to prolong
the shelf life of another
ingredient, which was blood.
Because this time
year, late autumn,
is also when people historically
harvested the excess
from their meat
production in summer.
And blood is very perishable.
It doesn't store well.
And one way of storing it
is to simply substitute
the water or milk as a
liquid in a dough with blood.
Bake a loaf, and then
pretty much just dry it.
And then when you want to eat
it later, like in March or June
or something like that, is to
break off pieces and simmer
them in broth.
And the very last thing--
the one up to the right
there is a blood
bread, by the way.
And the very, very
last thing that people
did was also loaves, but
not all in the same way as
in the southern sort
of more urban areas,
where the loaf is an
everyday ingredient
and consists of
mainly flour, water,
and a little bit of
salt. Up here they
made loaves as a really
special treat, maybe
like two or three of them.
And as with special
treats, being human,
we kind of want to make
them even more special.
So we put everything in there
that's expensive and fancy.
And in historical
times, obviously, that
was sugar, for
example, and spices.
So the further north you go in
the Nordic Region, this sweeter
and more seasoned the
breads are going to be.
And I remember,
like, growing up,
my grandma's rye
loaf is basically
like an egg-less
ginger sponge cake,
very, very sweet, almost
like at dessert, very tasty.
And obviously, like in the south
where it's an everyday thing,
you don't do that at all.
And you can follow this pattern
all through the Nordic Region
and look at how people
bake their bread.
You know, if you go
to Norway, you're
going to have pretty much the
same tendencies as in Denmark
and Sweden, with a difference
that Norway, with it's
sort of exposed coastal
climate, have much less firewood
available.
So they figured out more
efficient ways of baking.
So their flatbreads
are most often
going to be baked on,
like, a piece of sheet iron
or, like, a flat stone with
a little fire underneath it,
instead of that huge,
big wood-fired oven.
Same goes for the
semi-nomadic Sami population--
the indigenous population
of Scandinavia--
because they moved
around, naturally
they didn't have any ovens.
But they did take with
them their flat stones
to produce their traditional
gahkku flatbread.
Moving on to Iceland, a
country with even less trees
than Norway.
Ovens weren't really a thing
at all until the invention
and popularization
of the cast iron
stove, which on Iceland was
most often fired with peat.
And this is, like,
late-20th century.
And everyone who has
seen a cast iron stove
knows that the oven
is not very big.
You can't really do much in
there, maybe one loaf of bread.
What they do have
on Iceland, though,
are these sort of thermally
active and volcanic areas.
And quite often, next
to a village on Iceland,
you'll see something
like this, which is
basically next to a hot spring.
And people have dug little
holes in the ground.
Each family, each house,
will have their own hole,
and you'll have a
lid on top of it.
And the idea is
that, in the evening,
you'll go there with your
rye bread dough in a bucket,
put it down into the hole, put
the lid on, and then come back
in the morning.
And you're going to have
a steamed and cooked loaf
of bread.
And as far as I know,
this is the only example
of steamed bread
historically found in Europe.
And now we've gone through sort
of the base of the sandwich,
like the bread part of it.
And then we can start looking
at the toppings, which
is another factor that says
a lot about where they're
consumed.
And it says a lot about
the culture of that place.
This image here is
from a restaurant
in Copenhagen
called Schonnemann,
which is one of the most
traditional open-faced sandwich
restaurants.
And Denmark, you know,
with its position
as the land connection between
the Nordics and central Europe,
naturally being quite
a rich trading country,
happens also to be very rich
in terms of agriculture.
And you can really see
this on the sandwiches.
Look about that, you know?
There's no way
you're going to be
able to pick that up without
it all, like, falling apart
because there's just
so much toppings.
So you eat them sitting down on
the plate with knife and fork.
You often have them for,
like, a kind of nicer lunch.
You'll have beer and
you'll have Aquavit.
This says a lot about the
richness of the country.
If you were to go up to
where I grew up, like,
the sandwich would
be more like what
I said before, a piece
of crisp flatbread
with a simple layer of butter
and some cheese on it--
something you would probably
eat standing up after working
in the fields, for example.
Same goes for the Sami breads.
They would have
their Gahkku cakes
with them during the workday
out herding the reindeer,
simply eating them as
is with perhaps a piece
of dried reindeer on the side.
On the Faroe Islands, which
is a self-governed part
of Denmark, self-governed
territory belonging to Denmark.
They're clearly influenced
by the Danes and their bread
culture.
So you definitely find like
rye loaves and rye breads.
But the toppings
are quite different,
and they say a lot
about the Faroe Islands
and their geographical position
in the middle of the North
Atlantic.
Like these here, for example,
they're legs of mutton.
And one thing which is
quite interesting with-- not
only the Faroe Islands, but
with any country in the sort
of Northeast Atlantic
Region or any part of that--
is that salt is, like an
historical perspective,
a rare commodity.
Simply because there
are no trees there,
so you can't really evaporate
salt water in salt urns
like you would, for
example, in the UK
or in some of the northern
parts of Europe, like Germany.
And there's not enough
sunshine to produce water
from salt urns like in Spain,
or France, or Portugal, simply
by evaporating with solar power.
So salt, which is something
that most Western palates is
very tuned in to as a way
of distinguishing safe foods
from foods that are
going to make you sick,
is something that's
really rare here.
And it didn't really
become available
until modern shipping.
So we're talking
like 100 years ago.
Because of this, many of
the traditional preservation
techniques, they're salt-less.
And these legs of
mutton, for example,
they're simply just,
after slaughter, hung up
in a latticed house close to
the sea called the [INAUDIBLE].
And because of the location
of the Faroe Islands
in the middle of
the Gulf Stream,
it's a very stable
climate both in terms
of temperature and humidity.
And in these
particular conditions
they preserve the meat simply
by creating optimum conditions
for certain microbiological
flora and fauna.
Pretty much the same as what
we do with salt in the more
central parts of Europe.
Because salt, what it does
when you add salt to meat,
is that it induces
Lactobacillus fermentation which
produces lactic acid
and preserves the meat.
And the difference here in
flavor is quite significant.
Because most
Westerners are tuned
in to the very rich
sort of umami flavors
that lacto-fermentation gives--
whether it's cheese, or olives,
or ham, or whatever it is.
It's all the same kind
of indicative flavors
that we like, simply because
it used to mean safe food.
And for me, going to
the Faroe Islands, like,
having a piece of
that, like, my body
tells me that this is,
like, the worst idea ever.
You're going to die.
Even if you can see, like,
ten other people just munching
away, clearly enjoying it,
simply because my body never
learned that this is also a
safe way of preserving meats,
you know.
And if you don't find this
on top of your sandwich
in the Faroe Islands,
there's a good chance
you'll find some rhubarb
marmalade on it-- one
of the few things that grows
there that you can actually
turn into marmalade.
There are no berries at
all growing on that island.
And the same actually applies
for Iceland, as well--
loads of rhubarb everywhere.
Iceland, also being a
Northeastern Atlantic culture,
they have these salt-less
preservation methods
like the Faroe Islands.
And with their mutton, they
have a little addition.
And they smoke it in small
smokehouses like this.
And it's a sort of slow
cold-smoking process.
And then they also store
them in the smokehouse
after they're done.
And they, like, pick one down
from the rafters once a week
or something like that.
Being a country with
very, very few trees,
they figured out a different way
of creating the smoke and heat.
The reason why Iceland doesn't
have many trees is, you know,
you have the exposed climate,
and it's also very remote.
But mostly it's because
they have so many sheep
who eat all the
saplings and produce
sheep shit, which is
collected and then used
for fuel in the houses.
[CHUCKLE]
Doesn't sound super
appetizing, right?
So anyhow, that's perhaps
enough talking about sandwiches
as a cultural marker, even
though it's very interesting,
I think.
I'm going to talk
a little bit also
about how the book
was put together.
And initially, I wasn't very
keen on doing this project.
And I was kind of
offended when I
was asked to do it,
actually-- simply because most
people living in
the Nordic Region,
they don't identify
themselves as Nordic.
Because I am a Swede.
I'm not Nordic.
And most people
feel the same way.
And I thought it was kind
of a little bit like taking,
you know, Germany,
and some Portuguese,
and some French,
and some Italian
cooking and putting
into one book
and calling it the
"European Cookbook."
And it really turned
me off of the idea.
But then, after going back and
forth a little bit about this
and thinking more about
it, and I actually
realized that that
was the reason why
the book should be written.
And also that the
publisher had clearly
decided that the book
should be written,
and I didn't want
anyone else to do it.
But the fact that most people,
even within the region,
doesn't know what Nordic
food culture is, I thought
was really good motivation.
And the purpose of the
book is to explain this.
But not just by creating, like,
a very comprehensive collection
of recipes.
Because that kind
of already exists,
and it's not very interesting.
Because recipes are
just instruction
on how to produce something.
I also wanted to
provide a context.
So it's about half
recipes-- there's
700-and-something
recipes-- but there is also
more than 130,000
words of narrative text
to explain, like, where
the recipes come from,
and how they all tie together,
and why they make sense
where they were produced or
where they're still produced.
I really wanted the
book to be a kind
of a documentation of where
everything comes from,
historically.
Because without that,
you can't really
understand why we eat
the way we do today.
But I didn't want
it to become, you
know, like a romanticized
fairytale version of something
either.
So there's a little bit of that,
and then there's also a big
focus on what people actually
eat today in the Nordic
Region--- like a snapshot
of the actual food culture.
And because of this, on top of
those sort of ordinary gravlax,
and Herring, and
sheep-shit-smoked mutton
recipes, you're going to
find recipes like this one.
This is a thoroughly
regional specialty
from Sweden, the Taco Quiche.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was actually
a lot of debate
on whether recipes like this
were going to be included
in the book or not.
Because, like, why is
this a Swedish recipe?
It's quite interesting
to look at how
we define what comes
from where, and how we
define the identity of a dish.
And with these kind of
more recent recipes,
this was developed
over the last 30 years,
it's actually really
easy to figure out
how they developed, why,
and when it all started.
And then you can decide
whether it is Swedish or not.
And with this
particular recipe, like,
I know where it came from
because I kind of lived when
that happened, which is
not the case with most
of the recipes in the book.
Late '80s, early
'90s, spice companies
brought kind of the concept
of the taco to Sweden.
And it wasn't like a real,
authentic, Mexican taco,
but more of a sort of
bastardized Tex-Mex version,
and you could buy, like,
taco seasoning kits.
And it became
very, very popular.
And as with things
that become popular,
people start to
consume a lot of it.
And eventually, they get
a little bit tired of it,
and they lose the kind of
initial respect for it--
even if it's just, like,
a taco seasoning kit.
And then that's when
the interesting stuff
starts to happen.
Because that's when
people start to adapt it.
Because this happens
everywhere, all the time,
that we start to
adapt things just
to better suit the circumstances
where we practice our food
culture and to better
suit our own palates.
And this has led to
dishes like this one--
the merge between
Swedish mincemeat pie
and the taco quiche-- or a taco,
and hence, the taco quiche.
And it's like, back
to the discussion
about what makes a dish
a regional specialty.
If we compare this-- the
taco quiche-- with a dish
that most Swedes identify as
a very, very Swedish dish--
the sour herring, surstromming.
I don't know if anyone's
heard about that.
Yeah, there are a few nods.
It's the world's stinkiest food.
The sour herring is a
fish fermented with salt.
And that's not unique to Sweden.
Is actually not unique to
any country in the world,
because it's done
pretty much anywhere.
What's unique with
the sour herring
though, is that it's fermented
was salt in a tin can.
It produces a very particular
aromatic expression.
And if we look at
what they both are.
So, the Baltic herring
produced in a tin
can, it's produced in
the region, for sure.
But so is everything on
this picture, as well.
Like those nachos are
made in Sweden, of course.
Why would anyone transport
them from anywhere else
if you can make them on site?
Same with the store-bought
salsa, medium hot, and the taco
quiche.
So that's no longer
a defining factor
in what's decided what
is a regional specialty.
If we look at history, we
know that the herring, one
of the most iconic Swedish
dishes, it needs to
can to become what it is.
The tin can wasn't popularized
until the late-20th century.
So, you know, we can
pretty much assume
that the sour herring,
at these as we know it,
is not more than just
over a hundred years old.
It's very, very short in
a historical perspective.
The taco quiche, we know
that it came like late '80s
to early '90s, so
it's about 30 years.
It's also very short in
a historical perspective.
And in 500 years, like whether
it was 30 or 100 years,
it's not going to matter.
So those are not
defining factors either.
Cultural importance, with food
that's really easy to measure.
Because you can just watch and
how much people consume on it.
And if you take 100 Swedes,
and you put them in long row,
and you ask about
their eating habits.
And you ask them if they eat
sour herring and how often.
I would say that
maybe 20 of them
are going to say, yes,
I eat sour herring.
And out of those 20,
the vast majority
is going to eat it once a year.
It's going to be late summer.
There's going to
be midnight sun.
There's going to be
plenty of Aquavits.
If you ask the same 100
Swedes about the taco quiche,
there's going to be
many more than 20.
And there's going to be many
more of those people eating it
on an everyday basis.
So you can then just like ask,
which is the most Swedish dish?
And you can actually
have a little look.
It's easy to measure this.
If you just look at
Google, for example,
and you put the Swedish name
for taco quiche in there,
you're going to get
175,000 hits from a country
with 9.6 million people.
And I know that a taco quiche
doesn't exist anywhere else.
So they're all from there.
You're going to get a lot of
sour herring hits, as well,
but not so many for recipes.
That's for sure.
And this is actually
quite interesting
because you can really
look at the difference
between perceived reality, what
we think is our food culture,
and real reality, which is
what we actually consume.
And most of those
dishes that people think
is Swedish food culture, or
Nordic food culture, they are.
But they are not very
significant anymore.
The most common recipe
search from Sweden
is from something
called Kladdkaka,
means gooey chocolate cake,
which is also a recent recipe.
It was first kind of
conceived in the mid '70s,
something like that.
And you track it from
when it was first
published in a magazine
called "Allt on mat"
until it's developed
into what it is today.
And that has 750,000 hits.
That says quite a lot
about food culture.
So, anyhow, after doing
research for about two years,
we had loads of material.
I'd traveled all
across the region.
We put up a
web-based poll to ask
people what they thought
about their food culture
and to submit recipes.
And it was sort of time to
start compiling an index.
And I did it first.
I did a selection that
I felt represented
all the different parts
of the Nordic Region well.
And then I sent this
selection of recipes,
or the index, out to one expert
in each of the separate regions
or countries to review.
And they came back with
feedback on what was missing,
what was superfluous, what
was misspelled in Finnish,
and all kinds of
stuff like that.
And this resulted in a kind
of edited-down version,
containing
730-something recipes.
And I started actually
producing the content.
When that was done, the
whole content of the book
was sent out to all of
these experts one more time.
And they go to review the
actual methods and the content
in the recipes themselves
and send them back again.
Next step was to copy edit
the book, like you do.
And then the final step
was to send the whole book
to a guy named
Richard Tellstrom.
He's an associate
professor in ethnology
who specializes in the
meal as a cultural marker.
And he reviewed the
whole book and made sure,
like, all of the dates
where in order and all
that-- which they
weren't, obviously.
And I think one of
the great challenges
for me, as a food professional,
with writing a book
like this which is mainly
targeted on the person who
has quite a limited knowledge
about the topic of the book--
regardless if you are from
the Nordic Region itself
or from somewhere outside
of the region-- is
that you have to eliminate
all of the assumed knowledge.
And this is really difficult.
It sounds like an easy task.
You just have to explain how
everything actually works.
But it's so easy to
just slip little pieces
of assumed knowledge
into a method.
And like, I tried about
400 of the recipes
from the book myself, in
my own kitchen at home,
to see that they actually worked
in a home environment and all
that.
And the rest of
them were tried on--
out in the field when I
collected the recipes.
And when we had done that,
we sent about 100 recipes out
to different testers in
different parts of the world,
to see, like, to
really try to make sure
that we didn't have too
much assumed knowledge left.
And it was quite interesting
to see what came back.
So this is from me testing at
my house, different recipes.
The first one
there was lutefisk.
This is split pea soup.
This is some spinach dishes.
And then stuff like this
started coming back.
[LAUGHTER]
And this is a
really good example
where I thought I had
explained very, very
well how it was going to be.
Because this is something
called [SWEDISH].
It's a layer cake.
And all of the different
parts of this-- the cake,
the filling, the cream,
the various-- it's
perfectly executed.
Like, the person who's
tested this, she's
followed the recipe,
every detail.
And for me, I just hadn't
said how to assemble it.
[LAUGHTER] Because to
me, it's so obvious.
There's only one
way of doing it.
So I didn't even
think about that.
And this probably
tastes kind of the same,
but it looks completely wrong.
It looks nothing
like a layer cake
would in the Nordic Region.
This is another one that's
really interesting, as well.
So in Swedish this
is called [SWEDISH].
It's like a chocolate sponge
with a chocolate glaze
and some coconut
shavings on top.
And it turns out
that here in the US--
because this is an
American recipe tester who
tried this one--
the round cake tins,
they are 25 millimeters
smaller in diameter
than the Swedish ones.
So the cake is
almost 50% higher.
Like, who thinks about that
stuff when you write a book?
This here is also-- I don't
know what happened here--
but this is supposed
to be pickled herring.
Clearly there's
something wrong there.
Anyhow, that's "The
Nordic Cook Book,"
and thank you so
much for coming.
Does anyone have any questions?
AUDIENCE: You can probably
hear me right there.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
But the recording.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much
for coming to speak to us.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Well,
thanks for having me.
AUDIENCE: And I've
had your food.
And I am very glad that you're
a great writer and speaker.
What I wanted to ask
you is, you showed up
some things that seem that are
easy enough to make at home,
but a lot of what you
use in your own cooking
has to deal with
cooking over fire.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
anything to recommend for us,
with our tiny New York apartment
kitchens and fire regulations?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
Exactly.
We shouldn't violate those.
For me, like, it was really
important to remove the way
I cook professionally
from producing this book.
Because this-- there's
not a single recipe
in this book that's
actually mine.
So it's just a document
of what people actually
cook in their homes.
So what I cook at
Faviken and, like,
what was in the Faviken
book, my first book,
is quite different
from this stuff.
And I would say that out to the
730-something recipes, about 50
of them, no one is
ever going to cook.
They're just there
to explain something.
Either because they're
ridiculously complicated
and take several
weeks to reproduce,
or because you just
can't get the produce.
But the remaining
670-something recipes,
they are representative
of what people actually
eat in an everyday basis.
And if someone can cook it
in their little apartment
kitchen in Stockholm
or in Oslo, you're
probably going to be able to
cook it here, as well, I think.
They're quite accessible.
AUDIENCE: So there are a
lot of universal things
to what you talk about.
Because a lot of this
is very regional,
but I would say that
you can-- I guess,
when you come to
America, you see how
we do our tacos and all that.
So is there something that
you've learned about the, sort
of, the universal cook book?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yes.
There's one thing that's
actually really important.
And it's that there is no such
thing as a recipe that works
everywhere and every time.
And the idea of a recipe that's
bulletproof, it's just flawed.
Because it will never happen.
Because produce is different
from country to country,
and from time to time.
And we're working with
biological material,
so it's really something
that you have to adapt to.
And I think that, like, you
have to look at the recipe.
And by doing so, get instruction
on kind of how to proceed,
but then you still have
to be able to assess
whether something is good or
not, whether something is tasty
or not, and so on.
And you have to allow
yourself to also adapt
so that it suits the
circumstances where
the recipe is made.
And it's like-- if
you live in Italy,
you're not going to be able to
get fresh herring, for example.
But you can substitute
that with sardines.
It's not going to be the same,
but it's going to be tasty.
And maybe that's
sort of what matters.
Any other questions?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Magnus.
That was fascinating.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I have actually
the opposite question.
That is, by going through
this process for the last 24,
36 months, how has that actually
influenced your own cooking
within your own kitchen
and dish selection?
MAGNUS NILSSON: It's
actually like, I
didn't think it was going
to influence what I do much.
Because I thought,
well, it's home cooking.
But by doing this sort
of research process
and by putting
the book together,
I really realized
how much of what
I already do that has it's
origins in home cooking.
Because we know
home cooking, there
will be no professional cooking.
Like, that's where the
food culture comes from.
And there are
definitely dishes today
at the menu at Faviken
that have components
from this sort of
research process.
And I think that,
over the next years,
there is going to be much
more coming in, for sure,
that sort of ties into this.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
In your copious
research, is there
anything you can recall
really, really surprising
you or delighting you
that you discovered?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yes.
So the most surprising
thing to me,
having a special
interest in Nordic
cooking already
from the beginning
and doing quite
a lot of research
already for the restaurant
before this, what surprised me
the most was that I thought I
knew a lot about Nordic cooking
when I started, and
I realized halfway
through that I knew almost
nothing about the diversity
that you have in
the Nordic Region.
And that was really
very fascinating to see
how much there is.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a bit of a
different question.
I'm curious how you
experience a food culture
in a place like New York City?
When you're-- I don't know
how often you come here.
But when you do, do you go
to the fanciest restaurants,
or do you just stop
anywhere that looks good?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Well, I think
the thing with restaurants
is that-- the most important
with any restaurant
is that it kind of reflects
its place, regardless where
that is.
And for me, for example,
like, running a restaurant
in the countryside
of northern Sweden,
obviously that reflects
quite a lot into what we do.
We use produce from
the immediate region,
simply because it makes sense.
It's the best way for
us to get great quality.
And I think the same
goes for a city.
Like, you have to make as most
of the circumstances you have.
In a city, that'll probably
be, like, a very varied
and big influx of produce
and a huge influence
from different cultures.
So I think that's-- like, when
I come to a place like this,
that's what I like
to experience.
Because that's something that I
don't have at home, basically.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
favorite restaurants here?
[LAUGHTER]
MAGNUS NILSSON:
Oh, I have so many.
I have-- I come
here quite often,
and I have a lot of
favorite restaurants.
I'm not going to say, though.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: As you've
shown, the Nordic Region
is a fairly large region.
And when you get to some parts
of Greenland, for example,
you start to get
closer to Canada
than, like, the
core of Scandinavia,
and same for the
edges of Finland.
So I was wondering, have you
seen any interesting crossover
near these border areas?
MAGNUS NILSSON: Yeah.
You can actually see it
all through the region.
Because the Nordic Region can be
divided into cultural regions.
And it all has to do with who
made war with who and when.
Basically, who occupied who.
And the western part, the
biggest part of the Nordics,
has clearly been
influenced by Denmark.
Greenland, Iceland,
and the Faroe Islands
is clearly influenced by
Denmark and Danish culture,
in a historical perspective.
And then the kind
of eastern part,
which is today only
Finland, is influenced
by Sweden who occupied, like,
whole Baltic area a long time
ago.
And then you have Norway,
kind of in the middle,
which was Danish
for a long time,
but which was also in
a union with Sweden
until 1890-- which
is quite recently.
So there you can see two layers.
Like, you'll have a Danish
base, kind of mingled
in with the regional
specialties of Norway.
And then, stuff that happened
during the 19th century,
you'll have a lot of
Swedish influence,
as well-- because of the union.
And you see that everywhere.
Like Finland, you have
the whole Russian culture
coming into the country.
Greenland, you have the Innuit
culture mixing with Danish food
culture.
So it's really like,
it happens everywhere.
And sometimes we kind
of fool ourselves
that we are the first
couple of generations
who's been traveling a lot.
People have obviously been doing
that for a really long time.
And you can really see
that in the food culture.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Good.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Help me thank
Magnus for coming today.
MAGNUS NILSSON: Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much for
coming to listen to this.